where's the flashlight
Oh cuz I decided I want to film Jackson
playing five nights at Freddy's
so I'm gonna need something to get the
proper lighting since he wants the
lights off I was like can I use a
flashlight he said that's acceptable
there's a damn flashlight huh man he's
probably dead by now
right you died yet Oh No where is he oh
go away I don't like it I like it all oh
great thank you let's appreciate it
we're good doc this is not a great game
I mean it's a great game but come on man
you're 67% power and it's only 1:00 a.m.
you're being way too crazy with it power
does decrease though as the night goes
on it gets it gets in windows I beat the
first two days because I'm patient and I
have a sound strategy just watch the
doors and hardly ever pull up the camera
ducks the ducks right freakin here oh I
hate you
stop Foxy's speed-freak is the worst
game ever made but it's also the best
okay so this is going on YouTube there
I'm cool that I don't like it that's a
Rick I'm gonna have to relive this
terror eventually I won't turn up the
volume and will pump up the volume pump
up the volume
alright they're all pretty cool guy wait
is Freddy still on one a one rubber yeah
okay
spreading the bunny are pretty cool guys
suck duck is me foxy is a pretty cool
guy who is if is whoever one fear who
everyone is
whoever one was afraid oh no no no no no
no no no oh no no no no I want to check
it I don't want to check the I don't
wanna
I'm just gonna check it like [ __ ]
well that's not good don't waste energy
supposed to do I don't know guy oh
that's that's a that's obvious like we
stopped out you're wasting hi all man
you didn't check it enough so nice he's
put a peak in his head out I don't like
you foxy Knoxy is the meanest I'm gonna
murder you in your sleep foxy no no no
oxy lady did you see this
I see I'm seeing it you're seeing this
I'm seeing it I don't like it I don't
like it you'd stop eating light so much
okay Chucky Chucky Chucky anyone anyone
in anyone anyone anywhere anyone
anywhere oh this usually means they're
here
I don't worry one of their our hockey
hockey hockey how you done he get so
high so I'm a good time over there okay
not great I don't like it
did she leave yeah
okay I'm gonna insert that that one
picture
it's not broken it's still ain't given
FONSI okay my bro my friend it's not
broken it's just that's hard to set up
and it doesn't work for PC so yeah okay
light white you insisted to keep the
lights off so I can't film you but I can
film the game that's cool using my voice
so it's not like I'll react much up
until actually decide hey you're
occasionally deep voice with a slight
Lisp and my I don't even know how to
describe nice I sound like an annoying
jackass I don't hear you arguing so I
guess that's accurate you know I don't
like you I like you I hate you I'm gonna
kill you I'm gonna take out a gun and
and then you're gonna scream I'm a
father to a shooter we need to record us
playing heavy rain you want to go
through that again Rose we talked about
a second time go friendly music play if
you would kindly wait for me to read 6
a.m.
okay I'll do thank God can we pause this
we did it
we've um we made it to night for night
for all right six of seven because
there's awesome sevens customs less than
weekend okay um that's pretty good I
think we could beat this I mean it's not
that hard of a game it's scary but she
just I got some duct tape I'm gonna duct
tape Jackson to the chair unless he
finishes the game I'll hold on I got
some mouth
I've been told that they're outside but
I don't trust anyone
let's still up there geez there's a
flashlight
this is walk by these like six times I'm
so stupid
ah stick hurt hold on
we can charge while violin recording
because the wire is too short where's
Jackson everybody yeah see my dumb face
all right here we go
I got an idea all right I'm gonna get
proper lighting now like now I got
stationary lights and I can make him
film you while you play yeah let's do
this
hey hold on let me see what it looks
like with the light off that's
terrifying oh my god it's just your face
in the darkness make a scary face not
the duck face Jackson